alors chaque soir on rend hommage aussi
au génie que notre belle télévision en
vendée et ce soit on commence avec nos
champions toutes catégories
c'est ce de la bataille des couples et
alors c'est sûr c'est sur tf6
vous connaissiez le programme de la
chaîne arte il est bas vous imaginez
tout l'inversé vous obtenez la bataille
des je vous le dis on débute avec notre
petit couple préféré c'est chloé et
virgile alors comme ça fait plusieurs
jours que le couple bat de l aile la
production a décidé de les re soudée oui
ils ont donc organisé une épreuve basée
sur la confiance et l'esprit d'équipé
juste pour rapprocher nos tourtereaux
lité l'idée elle était très sympa à la
base ce qu'ils arrivent dès l'arrêt pas
de s'en prendre plein la gueule un
l'optique
sauf que du côté de chloé ça fonctionne
moyens regarder à gauche à gauche à
gauche à gauche à gauche
tous droits que droit pardon faiblesse
de l'état
non non
poissonspas son voisin au hasard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable la bataille des couples
est passé en mode koh lanta avec une
épreuve très sympathique dans laquelle
les filles devaient deviner ce qu'elle
touche et mais les yeux bandés
alors attention les teintes ont donc les
candidates ont tout réalisé ce qu'on
appelle une benhaim dans le litige
j'avais une pénalité lui demande d'aller
faire des trucs regarder avance avance
avant stop met les mains stop
tanaka n'en sais rien c'est moi
et c'est l'extérieur
mais je te promet donc un témoin sais
rien je te c'est des trucs vous voulez
mais ça
à
c'est chouette
oui la balade
dis moi si
[Applaudissements]
oui à la vie c'est pour jouer
c'était pas loin d'ici dans ses talons
de studio incroyable ça c'est les
éléphants bien joue la comme moi sur les
sur les serpents insectes et au sein
mais aussi des à ceux qui devaient
tomber sur je me rappelles tu est
allongée ah ouais j'ai ça ne dérange pas
ton les insectes ça va annoncer des
crapauds annoncé permanent que je peux
pas le croire c'est vraiment pourquoi
qui s'est pas j'ai dit avoir un crapaud
dans ma vie je sais pas si on ne peut
pas dépasser betis et je me suis raide à
la fois que j'en à capot c'est un
plateau des parties sur vais marier avec
sa première alors j'aimerais faire aussi
un petit coucou à dylan dylan c'est le
mec il a vraiment des convictions dylan
et il est bien sûr dans la bataille des
couples on aime bien au pc est
sympathique mais le problème c'est que
ces convictions elles durent dix
secondes vous allez voir c'est le mec
qui change radicalement d'avis le plus
rapide regarde
[Applaudissements]
traduisez fait mille ce soir à tout à
l'heure
mais on épure mon droit stratégie en a
un qui fait en ladder nous les petites
stratégiste secrète comme ça bâtard b
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant on va passer à un autre
sujet vous prenez la bataille des
couples vous enlevez une île déserte
vous rajoutez des tatouages très
bienvenu dans les marseillais sur w9
alors vous le savez ma marseillaise
préféré c'est maija il va souvenez-vous
il ya quelques semaines on a eu le coup
de foudre pour elle lorsqu'on a
découvert que c'était un jukebox à
insultes vraiment petit rappel de maeva
regarder merci anissa est un mot pour
les marseillais peut-être bas vous aussi
je vous ai tout ce qu'il fait bon sauf
celle-là mais
vers toi qui t'en vas peut-être de
souffler ok mon retour en france bercy
elle n'est pas belle vallar vibrer dans
la machine pour notre plus grand plaisir
c'est parti pour le top 3 des insultes
incroyable de maeva regardez c'est là
[Musique]
moi j'ai la force si vous êtes d'humeur
caisse on vous a toujours mangé avant
que vous mangez donc de merveilleux
la maman l'a aimé voilà déjà trois
enfants tous étant hors droits soit
menée
[Musique]
je vais d'abord j'ai trouvé qu'on se
promène dans les ordres
maintenant
la france a effectivement présents
qu'ils ne connaissent pas encore je vous
présente et benji regard des belges
alors pas de notre benji alors on
assiste à une très grosse embrouille
entre julien temps tiquer 1 l voilà des
personnages par des marseillais et mila
et le fameux benjamin eux passent par là
et à 6 par hasard à la scène alors on se
dit est-ce qu'il va intervenir
est-ce qu'il va essayer de les raisonner
est-ce qu'il va protéger milla est bon
en fait pas du tout
le mec so foot otages regardez comment
ils peuvent être aussi cruel d'un coup
il change la vie me ces camions de
comportement ça vous allez faire espérer
pour l'été le change mais moi j'ai dû
moi te le dis j'ai retourné à tête de
toute ma famille et moi que tu chantais
dans les frigos exactement alors
coupable alors pourquoi faire la balance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la saison mercredi tu as deux
types de public
tu as ta les papis et les mamies qui
vont avoir des chiffres et des lettres
et pendant ce temps là ils envoient
leurs petits-enfants sur guye alors le
public de cully c'est le plus chaud de
france tu peux leur annoncer n'importe
quel truc je vous le jure
ils sont comme des oufs regarder
ouais
et un bonus temps qui vous servira pour
la demi finale il y a les bleus vont
tenter par et ghana au galop en toute
liberté
bravo part de la dérive inazuma eleven
ares et city à bolton et les
charentaises font leur grand retour
figurez vous
est ce que vous connaissez cet homme tu
veux montrer quelqu'un que vous
connaissez cet homme s'il vous plaît ils
ont mal à cet homme si vous connaissez
mes chers ferrand on ne sait quoi
richard ferrand il est social il est
président la sent la chaîne la2 passion
toujours su faire taire les débuter et
faire taire les députés alors autant au
début il essayait d'être poli et
d'écouter un peu les parlementaires
autant maintenant je vous dis il a dit
nu comme au total un plat micro direct à
l'assemblée regarde
beaucoup de paroles et peu d'actions
monsieur le ministre chaussez vos bottes
quitté rue de varenne et venez sur les
territoires rencontrer merci madame le
député qui ai grandi par cette décision
c'est madame on doit me sur l'ensemble
des députés sont avec vous mais quatre
ans mercy
il ya eu des rattrapages mais le
rattrapage de salaire suffisant mais
sans ce sens que moi je dis que des
publicités bien votre proposition
reconnaissant le burn out et pur bonheur
si madame rubin préciser tout de même
que chaque député de n'importe quel
parti
ouais à un temps limité de parole et
c'est en coupe le micro systématiquement
à ces pays devraient faire ça aux
victoires de la musique
invasion il préfère ça ça rigolait ou
victor nomiya fête de la musique il
voulait faire ça ça nous l'avait demandé
sur twitter je vous le dit c'est notre
petit bonheur d'hier solange qui appelle
les voyants de la chaîne idf1 savoir si
elle va se rapprocher avec son ex mari
et leur tour aujourd'hui son prénom
solange s'il vous plaît bah aiguille
j'ai pas bien compris la vie et son
prénom c'est il m'a dit c'est ça fait
mal dit mike leigh malgré maidi son âge
révolu s'il vous plaît solange m'a dit
oui mais son âge s'il vous plaît bybee
il miley était né le pen 66 devant lui
16 septembre 70 c'est que vous
connaissez depuis combien de temps
miley
tristitude
[Applaudissements]